[Music]
it's the world's third largest industry
but that was before the covet 19
pandemic brought tourism
to a screeching halt that's been
especially hard for europe
the world's number one travel
destination in years past
tourism brought regular surpluses to
european budgets
border shutdowns and restrictions have
shown just how many jobs are dependent
on foreign visitors
and it's not just airlines and tourism
companies but also hotels
cafes and businesses all dependent on
bustling travel
but with the full coffers of the past
also came growing tensions across europe
higher living costs gentrification and
frustrations for locals in many cities
like here in barcelona but also venice
and amsterdam
will tourism ever bounce back to its
pre-pandemic highs
and could this extended off-season be an
opportunity
to rethink travel for the future
hello and welcome to deutsche welle's
coveted 19 special i'm steven beardsley
in berlin it's good to have you with us
a tourism may be a double-edged sword
for europe but the pandemic has reminded
the continent just how important the
sector is for its economy
especially for jobs john philip schultz
brings us this report from spain's
canary islands
while the season is coming to an end in
most of europe the real action is just
beginning on the spanish island of
fuerteventura
italian petra uber lehner has lived here
for 15 years
she runs a kitesurfing school after
months of coronavirus restrictions
she's now hoping for winter vacationers
the subtropical climate here is pleasant
in the colder months and it's nearly
always windy
i hear they should arrive again flights
and also we
we have a lot of reservations i mean not
like
for long term or more like asking for
information how the situation is looking
like but now there are there's a lot of
people from all over europe
interested in coming here and i hope it
can be possible for everybody
victor cobelo is far less optimistic he
runs a small country hotel in the
interior of the island
the restaurant is doing reasonably well
but he says the hotel business has
collapsed because for months people
all over the world have been warned
against travel to spain
he has already had to let go several
employees on his small team
and he sees few signs of improvement
about two-thirds of all workers on
fuerteventura live from tourism
the crisis is sitting the african and
south american migrant workers on the
island particularly hard
many lost their jobs from one day to the
next and do not appear in any official
statistics
hundreds of migrants work without papers
in the hotels and restaurants on the
island
according to local aid organizations
unlike other residents
they are not entitled to any government
support and for them
the absence of tourists is becoming more
and more of an existential threat
the island government doesn't even try
to put a gloss on things
it is now pinning all its hopes on a
meeting of the eu tourism ministers at
the end of the month
the government commissioners hopes rest
on travel corridors
his government's idea on arrival and
departure the island could test
all tourists for the corona virus and
existing quarantine regulations could be
lifted
i hope in that meeting 28th of september
in europe they are able to say okay all
european countries decide
how to proceed to make those tests in
the airport
on the port the government of the
canaries and also for toronto
we have the budget we have the money to
make it possible
they could start airport tests as early
as tomorrow the politicians said
it would be expensive but it would be
worth it if planes finally landed on the
island
regularly again so the view there from
spain's canary islands
let's look at the broader woes facing
global tourism
the pain started in the first three
months of the years
of the year rather as asia locked down
and that led to a 22 percent pullback in
the sector
and while those numbers have improved
slightly in some regions the overall
tourism industry is looking at a
whopping 60 to 80 percent contraction
for the full year
and that would put as many as 120
million
direct tourism jobs at risk
and let's talk now to richard weston
he's a senior research fellow at the
lancashire school of business in the uk
where he focuses on tourism richard it's
good to have you on the show
how dependent has europe become on
tourism
uh yeah i think that um
probably as a region europe isn't more
dependent than lots of other regions in
the world but
there are parts of europe itself
particularly spain and italy greece
which have become very dependent on on
tourism perhaps uh
15 of their gdp comes from from just
this one sector that's staggering what
does that mean for jobs
they have the job that's a a lot of jobs
and of course it's not just the
the directly employed people in in the
in the industry but all the ancillary
support staff you know the
the um the travel companies and and the
laundry companies and everybody that
does anything that might be connected to
tourism so the supply chains
are also largely impacted you could
probably add 50
again to that figure what is that
well let me ask first at the same time
you have all these jobs but then
the old business model in some ways
wasn't that great a lot of these cities
amsterdam venice barcelona really
chafing at the amount of tourists that
were coming through their cities
um and what it had done culturally what
it had done to gentrification things
like that
certainly yeah some of the cities have
become
far too successful if you like
and this is now causing problems for the
local
populations the resident population in
terms of
increasing property prices and
local shops closing because there aren't
enough local buyers
so some some places and i know barcelona
in particular has started to address
this
in terms of of the attract and disperse
model where they
they're not trying to put people off but
once they arrive then trying to push
them out into the wider region
um but he career there are lots of
places in in europe which were
clamoring for more tourists you know
some of the
the um the new member states in in the
balkans and places like that
uh where they they were under tourists
rather than over tourists you know
well now it looks like everyone is under
tourists how long can we expect things
to last as they are how long will this
industry be down
right how long is a piece of string
um that's a
a very good question i i think certainly
um this year will be written off um
we're already seeing a second spike and
so i think you know that
we're coming towards the end of the
primary tourist
season anyway but but i think you know
we're seeing this second spike we're
likely to get more local lockdowns
more interruptions to travel more
borders closing
uh more quarantine periods so all of
these things will have a
negative impact on on tourism
um i i think the long-term impact is
likely to be felt
for for many years perhaps up to a
decade
and it just does depend on on
the progress of of the virus and whether
we have a
vaccine if we don't have a vaccine an
effective one
then that means that we will be looking
forward to social distancing
for uh the foreseeable future
and of course that has an impact on the
capacity of hotels and restaurants
cafes beaches even um and so that's
going to have a
a serious impact on certainly the mass
market
so the the places that were relying
heavily
on tourism for those areas were that
attracted tourists but they were more
dispersed
then obviously it's less of an issue
because there's that
natural spacing going on between people
all right richard weston joining us from
the university of lancashire thank you
very much
my pleasure and once again it's time for
your questions answered by our science
correspondent derek williams
[Music]
do we need to stop taking medications
for high blood pressure
do they make covid19 worse
this is one of those questions that's
been subjected to a lot of intense
scrutiny over the months
early on in this pandemic there was a
lot of worry among
health care professionals that certain
medications called
ace2 inhibitors which are used to lower
blood pressure
that they might actually make people
more susceptible
to covet 19 that's because we think they
might increase
levels of what's called angiotensin
converting
enzyme to or or ace2 in your cell
membranes
and we confirmed at an early stage that
that just like with
other coronaviruses the ace2 receptor is
kind of the door knob
that that sars co2 uses to to open the
door
to your cells so the theory was that
having more ace2 receptors would
probably be a bad thing
however stopping blood pressure
medication suddenly can also have
serious side effects so the medical
advice was
keep taking your meds until we know more
well fast forward six months and and we
do know more and guess what
it turns out the opposite could be true
um a recent
large-scale meta-analysis of of 19 other
studies
conducted by british researchers shows
that taking those
hypertension medications doesn't put you
at greater risk of a severe coveting
outcome
in fact the study says they might
actually reduce the risk
of disease severity although that wasn't
proven definitively but really
i think whether they actually help or
not is almost beside the point um
just knowing that we're now pretty sure
ace2 inhibitors really
don't make covet 19 worse will be a big
load off the minds of the people who
take them
and the doctors who prescribe them as
well
[Music]
all right our science correspondent
derek williams there and finally here's
a special flight for
australian travelers with nowhere in
particular to go
qantas is offering a seven-hour scenic
flight called
great southern land ground australia on
october 10th
it will allow passengers to catch a
glimpse of popular attractions such as
luru the great barrier reef and sydney
harbour
tickets cost 570 us dollars apiece and
sold out in just a few minutes
you